I hope that the law students today are
having to watch butter sing what what in
the butt in their classrooms I hope that
that's the legacy of this case you know
South Park is the raunchy animated show
following the foul-mouthed adventures a
fourth grader Stan Kyle Kenny and
Cartman for 19 seasons the controversial
show has provided cutting cultural
commentary but it's also established an
important legal precedent that expands
your free speech rights when anybody
creates anything basically you know
there are some exceptions that thing
automatically gets copyrighted and for
the most part it can't be used in
certain ways without permission but
there are some really important
exceptions to that rule and there are
some really important places where we
say actually members of the public no
matter who they are can use this thing
for all sorts of reasons without getting
permission
that's Parker Higgens the director of
copyright activism at the Electronic
Frontier Foundation in San Francisco in
2010 AFF became unlikely allies with
media giant Viacom the owner of South
Park who was sued by brownmarkfilms a
8th episode called Canada on strike
parodied a popular viral video it was an
episode where butters the South Park
character remakes
the viral music video what what in the
butt and it's a parody and you know you
see butters acting as the role of the
singer and and it's a pretty close copy
but in South Park animation style and
that's that kind of parody is canonical
fair use there are typically four things
the courts will look at when determining
fair use does the work transformer add
meaning to the original what's the
nature of the work that's being copied
how much of the work is used and does it
affect the market for the original work
PFF and Viacom argued that the use
the music video was fair use as it was
purity commenting on the viral video
trend one of the one of the places where
the judge in inground mark cites our
brief is when he says that in that
lawsuits alleging infringement can be
kind of a shakedown operation they can
be just a way to get money either
through a settlement or or if the threat
of a lawsuit might cause them to before
before you actually sue causes the other
people to say okay fine we'll license it
and there are instances like this where
you know you could imagine South Park
wants to use this thinks it's a fair use
but just pays because otherwise it will
be a thing hanging over them or thing
they have to litigate over and over and
it's you know and that's that is the
environment for a lot of things and it
creates what what is known as a
permissions culture where people aren't
exercising their fair use rights and so
you kind of forget they exist the case
eventually made its way to the Seventh
Circuit Court of Appeals in 2012 where
the court ruled in favor of South Park
and Viacom the ruling is vastly
important to the creative class and one
of the most cited cases in Entertainment
Law in the last five years because it
says that a fair use lawsuit can be
stopped before going to trial which can
help content graders avoid the huge cost
of litigation brought on by frivolous
copyright lawsuits under the Supreme
Court it's the highest precedent that
you can have is is that you know this
butters video is fair use that's really
helpful in terms of pointing to hey look
it's it's a large portion that's copied
and it's done commercially and it's done
you know without that many changes it's
not you know transformative in in a way
that you might think but it's still fair
use so in terms of that precedent
super-important and then the other thing
is is the is the precedent the
procedural thing the thing that's a
little less less fun but the fact that
it can stop lawsuits early I hope that
law students today are having to watch
butters sing what what in the butt in
their classrooms I hope that that's the
legacy of this case